hot breath what was it about dane that
erupted what was his luck what was that
spark
it's just dude you know he was uh
clean yet edgy good looking
you know young energetic
you know what i mean he uh he
i mean people talk about giving so funny
people like you gotta give you
you put your stuff on instagram gotta
give it away
they did that back with napster he
gave his whole album away on napster it
was him
people weren't stealing it he stole it
and gave it away
and made it look like people then people
just stealing his stuff but they were
sharing it
he knew back then you need people to
share your
get them into you first and then you can
charge them later
and that's kind of coming back now like
andrew schultz
exactly these guys are like just it
give it away
you know um because the model was a
couple years ago
or five years ago you work your ass off
comedy central or one of these people
give you a special
you do an hour and then you're in now
you can
now you can sell out rooms or theaters
small theaters and
build from there that's gone
nobody knows why anybody gets this
people have specials you're like what
that's not even stand up that's not
that's a story like
yeah that's a ted talk i don't even know
what the that is
i didn't laugh for three minutes
i didn't and when i did laugh i
just went ah that's not stand up
stand up is every 30 seconds stepping on
someone's neck
you i'm making you laugh i have
people come up to me after my show dude
you made me laugh the whole time what
yeah yeah what the what did you
just see
well i saw a comic a couple weeks ago i
you know i laughed but it wasn't the
whole time it was you know
i think all right well i don't know what
the that is